let's bring in tommy lahren host of no
interruption on fox nation and gerald
rivera
fox news correspondent at large welcome
to both of you hi uh thanks for being
here um
this is this is a horrific situation
and every weekend we see more shootings
across the nation
so today moments ago in the white house
briefing room genesaki was asked what's
the president's reaction to this he
hasn't talked about it a whole lot
and here's what she said i'm not going
to get ahead of
his comments or remarks later this week
but it is an area where the president
feels
a lot a great deal of the crime we're
seeing as a result of gun violence
you can expect he'll speak to that and
his commitment to continuing to address
gun violence and gun safety in the
country
all right so apparently we're going to
hear something from the president
on this and i would just mention before
going uh
to you to you both keisha and bottoms
in the mayor in atlanta said you know
it's partly just a
coveted reopening problem because she
says her city reopened
too soon and that's the reason that
they're seeing so much crime
tommy what do you say
how blissfully ignorant are these
democrats they blame our second
amendment rights law-abiding americans
who exercise their second amendment
rights going after
gun control talking about guns and then
they go after a reopening allowing
businesses
and allowing people to go on and live
their normal lives they blame those two
factors but they don't blame the defund
the police movement that the democrats
have been placating
for the last year and a half or more in
these cities led by democrats that have
defunded or otherwise reallocated or
shorted their police departments
that's where you're seeing homicides
rise that's where you're seeing a
culture of lawlessness
there's a certain segment of americans
who have watched this unfold
they know that there are no consequences
if consequences exist at all
they're going to be small consequences
you're seeing in new york city looters
not being charged after what happened
last summer the message is being sent
out you can do whatever you want
the police are outnumbered they can't do
much of anything to you if you are
caught in your crimes
and so this is what happens when the
inmates run the prison you know
i mean geraldo it does feel like that it
feels like
it's it's a little bit of a no-go zone
in some of these
places you look at what's going on in
washington square park in new york
and you know let me put up the pictures
of the two
uh da's you've got um darcel clark
in the bronx and cyrus vance jr who
happens to be spending
a lot of his focus on uh tax charges
that he's trying to cultivate against
president trump meanwhile though they
say you know what we're not going to
prosecute what happened
in the riots in new york city where
people broke the windows took
all the merchandise out ran away with it
they stole cars and you know drove them
all around the city
and you know perpetrated more crimes
listen to this this is jessica
bettencourt she's a new york city
business owner watch this
i think it's just disgusting it's
outrageous the way we
getting treated no one made an effort to
even
come to the stores and say you know what
can i get some surveillance can i get
some fingerprinting
to see if we could catch these looters
no efforts were made by the city
no efforts made by the city to prosecute
any of these 400-some people geraldo
martha that's the office where i began
my legal career
my daughter simone followed me in that
new york da's office
you know they say they're overwhelmed
with covid cases because the courts were
closed
and yet they're still investigating as
you mentioned trump on these lame
tax charges they're dropping uh other
charges against the 2020
june 2020 looters why are they dropping
those charges
because the kids who stole and burned
were protesting
the death of george floyd i mean that's
absolutely baloney you can't
pick and choose laws must be upheld
equally shame
on the grown-ups who justify lawlessness
those weren't protesters they were
crooks
you have all these deaths everywhere
there's a ghetto civil war
murders the number one cause of death
for young black men in america
it is the civil rights issue martha of
our time you know
if you don't prosecute these kinds of
crimes
it simply sends the message that it's
okay right you can do it you can do
whatever you want
and then you look at a different level
of this washington square park in new
york and of course we've got a mayor's
race on going here and i don't know if
there's any indication that
anybody really has the spine to crack
down on this i guess we'll see what
happens
but but the people who are hanging out
at these rave parties in washington
square park say
we're going to be here every single day
just like the police are we are too
because this is as much our home as it
is other residents have to live here
if you can't accept the fact that i'm
living within my first amendment
constitutional rights
then my friend you're living in the
wrong country and democracy is not for
you
uh they tried curfews in the park tommy
um but none of that has worked to sort
of restore some kind of you know
peaceful environment in this part of new
york
they have free reign and this isn't just
the defund the police movement that
we've seen over the last year and a half
this is also
can be attributed to a lot of the
policies on the book a lot of the bad
public policies when you have felon
coddling policies when you have crime
reclassification
when you have cashless bail when you
have reduced sentence saying of course
people are looking and saying why can't
i just do what i want and then
add on to that that you can pass it off
as justice or you can get a get out of
jail free card quite literally
if you say that you are being oppressed
or you are being in some way this is a
product of racism
then you feel as though you can do
whatever you want but it's not just
happening
in inner cities it's not just happening
in areas that were already rough
neighborhoods this is happening in
atlanta in places like buckhead this is
coming to a city a suburb near you
and people are going to start to
understand what it looks like when
social media hashtags
become public policy it's dangerous and
reckless yeah
i want to finish and get one last
thought from you geraldo if i may this
is james craig
the former detroit police chief
on sunday morning with marie i believe
questions
okay let me just start by saying that
our profession is in a crisis right now
some of the mayors in these cities are
failing miserable let's look at chicago
lori lightfoot talks about what's
dangerous the cops are dangerous
no she's dangerous we can talk about the
failed leadership
uh but where's the support for the men
and women this anti-police rhetoric
it is not a surprise that police
officers are leaving in large numbers
geraldo the support for the men and
women is gone and
we all know that president trump showed
great support for law enforcement across
this country
we also know that there have been some
very tragic incidences that have
happened across the country
but now you've got a situation where
people like nobody has their back what
do you think president biden needs to
say
to law enforcement in this country that
defund the police was the stupidest
social movement of our time
to take the uh the guns out of the hands
of the cops
or to take their uh their community
support away
was appalling you have now the opposite
is happening though i see
martha i see a comeback the class the
recruitment class and the
police academy now over fourteen
thousand uh
it's a record many minorities are
signing up
the community is coming back to the cops
eric adams the former police captain is
the leading candidate
in tomorrow's mayoral race uh the people
of new york have gone from defund the
police and
take a billion dollars out of their
budget to support the police
law and order is the most important
issue of this time martha well
i hope you're right i hope you're right
for this city and for cities across the
nation
um because it this is out of control out
of control thank god those two kids
are okay but i think that that image
should stay in everybody's mind
across this country about how rampant
and how um
you know people feel like they can get
away with whatever they want right now
geraldo thank you tommy thank you
good to see you both